find the area bound by the lines x plus  y equals five x plus two y equals six  and the y axis  first solve for the y intercept of the  line x plus y equals five  this has a y intercept equal to five  now solve for the y-intercept of the  other line by substituting x is equal to  0 giving 2y equals 6 or y equals 3.  now find the intersection of the two  lines  to solve this system of equations we  subtract x plus y equals 5 from x plus  2y equals 6 which gives the equation y  is equal to 1.  substituting back in gives that x is  equal to 4.  4 1 is the intersection of the two lines  to find the area of this triangle note  that its base can be found as five minus  three equals two and its height is equal  to four  so its base times its height over two is  equal to two times four over two which  is equal to 4 and that's the answer